ja wir wollen anfangen mit ganz
aktuellen Bildern von heute morgen aus
der Stadt nipro eine von vielen
ukrainischen Städten wo heute morgen
wieder die Kraftwerke angegriffen wurden
von russischen Kamikaze drohen und von
russischen
Marschflugkörpern hier in nephro also
das Kraftwerk was brennt nach
verschiedenen Explosionen und wir haben
den ukrainischen Präsidenten volumenski
der sich in einem Hilferuf an die Welt
richtet er sagt in den letzten acht
Tagen hat Russland 30 % der ukrainischen
Kraftwerke zerstört 30% in nur 8 Tagen
und wir können das ein bisschen
vorrechnen in der auch in der Ukraine
wird es jetzt sehr kalt es wird
natürlich Winter bis zu -20 25° sind
dort und wenn es nur 8 Tage gedauert
hatten 30% zu zerstören und wir sehen
heute morgen geht das weiter viel
Kraftwerke wohnen seit dem frühen Morgen
bombardiert dann ist zum Wintereinbruch
und ab 0 Grad sozusagen überhaupt gar
keinen Strom überhaupt gar keine Heizung
mehr in der Ukraine vorhanden ja warum
ist der Russland so erfolgreich mit
seinem Kampf ausschließlich gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung nicht etwa gegen das
Militär wir schauen uns die Aufnahme
noch mal von gestern an aus Kiew und wir
sehen hier oben die Shahid 136 die
iranische die Karte Drohne die eben
fliegt bis sie einschlägt und dort ein
weiteres Wohnhaus gestern getroffen hat
eine ukrainische
elektrizitätsfirma getroffen hat und
eben auch in Kraftwerk angegriffen hat
und wir gucken uns das ganze jetzt
einmal aus einer anderen Perspektive an
und hier sehen wir weshalb diese Drohnen
so gefährlich und so tödlich sind hier
oben sehen wir wie die Drohne ankommt
und wir sehen gleich wie sie hier auf
ihr Ziel zufliegt und wir sehen aber
dann auch gleich wie ein ukrainische
Luftabwehrrakete abgeschossen wird aber
die Drohne verfehlt wir achten einfach
mal darauf wie das ganze aussieht die
Drohne geht runter die ukrainische
Flugabwehrrakete wird abgeschossen
gestartet und verfehlt die Drohnen wir
sehen uns das ganze noch einmal an und
sehen jetzt hier die beiden die einer
einander vorbeifliegen wenn man so
möchte hier die Drohne die weiter auf
ihr Ziel zu fliegt und hier die
Flugabwehrrakete die an der Drohne
vorbeigeflogen sind und warum ist das so
wir sind jetzt gleich die Explosion und
sehen auch den Einschlag der Drohne
man konnte also nicht dagegen
verteidigen ja warum ist das so dieser
Flugabwehrraketen arbeiten in zwei
Bereichen nämlich zum einen
Infrarotbereich also gucken sich an wie
warm ist mein Ziel und zum anderen im
UV-Bereich gucken Sie also an wie groß
ist mein Ziel kann ich das erkennen es
ist anders als die Sonnenstrahlung und
so weiter und in beiden bietet die
Shahid 136 fast keine Angriffsfläche sie
hat also fast keine Infrarot Struktur
weil sie eben sehr sehr kühl ist weil
sie sehr kleinen Motor hat und auf der
anderen Seite ist sie auch sehr
windschnittig und hat nur zwei Meter
länge etwa weshalb sie kaum sichtbar ist
für die Flugabwehrraketen das heißt
woran bleibt es am Ende an Polizisten
auf der Straße die mit ihren Pistolen
mit ihren Maschinengewehren versuchen
abzuschießen die haben wir aus zwei
verschiedenen Perspektiven die
Polizisten die gestern versucht haben
Kiew zu verteidigen wir sehen ja 1 2 3 4
5 Polizisten die mit Maschinengewehren
in die Luft schießen und versuchen eben
diese Drohne abzuschießen aber ohne
jeden Erfolg wir sehen gleich noch mal
wie die Drohne jetzt trotzdem an ihn
vorbei fliegt und eben hinter den
einschlägt wir sehen gleich eine
mächtige Explosion hier auf einen
Stellwerk der
ukrainischen fahren das heißt hier wurde
ein Bahnhof angegriffen bzw eben das
Stellwerk so dass dortheft Zugverkehr
auch nicht weitergehen kann solche
Bilder also erreichen uns aus der ganzen
Ukraine wo im russischen
Marschflugkörper und russische Kamikaze
drohen ein groß der ukrainischen
kritischen Infrastruktur zerstören
nochmal das sind keine militärziele das
sind zivile Ziele für 30 Millionen
Ukrainer die noch in diesem Land leben
und dort gerne den Winter überleben
würden ja wie sieht das Ganze an der
Front aus ganz anders hier haben wir
weiter so dass die Russen überhaupt
nicht vorankommen dass sie in den
Ukrainer nichts entgegenzusetzen haben
und wir sehen das hier einmal dass sie
sich immer immer öfter ergeben hier
sehen wir einen russischen Soldaten der
auf die Ukraine dazu kommt mit erhobenen
Händen und das sind diese neuen mobil
gemacht und da gibt es eine eine
ukrainische Hotline die eben sagt wenn
ihr nicht kämpfen wollt wenn ihr auch
nicht gekämpft habt gegen uns dann könnt
ihr euch direkt ergeben und wir werden
euch gut behandeln und euch wird nichts
passieren dass Aufnahmen hier aus herson
im Süden das Aufnahmen aus dem Osten aus
der Region Raki auch dort russische
Soldaten die nicht gekämpft haben die
sich direkt den Ukrainern ergeben
einfach auf Sie zukommen und sagen Leute
wir wurden mobil gemacht wir wollten
nicht mobil gemacht werden wir müssen
gegen euch kämpfen wir wollen nicht
gegen schämpfen und wir ergeben uns das
heißt dieser starke Kontrast von auf der
einen Seite der russischen Armee die in
nirgendwo im Land vorankommt und sich ja
zu Hunderten ergibt den Ukrainern ohne
zu kämpfen und auf der anderen Seite die
russischen Luftwaffe und die russischen
Raketenangriffe eben auf ukrainische
zivile Infrastruktur das das Bild im
Krieg um die Ukraine nach knapp acht
Monaten
[Musik]